to be honest right now I think you guys
are so privileged your parents did you a
favor by bringing into this country
right yeah my mom did thank you Mom yeah
but you think your dad did nothing to
play in that role well you had to you
had to do it I told my mom that at least
that's the least he owed my mind
I'm not gonna explain my dad's situation
because you guys are trying to make me
experience my father I'm not gonna do
that okay do you understand me but he
owed my mom down he owned my mom he owed
my mom you're coming and saying oh
Zimbabwean cultures they are apparently
worked hard in a country that right now
and bro no they don't really open when
you had me I didn't choose for him to
have me no he has a responsibility he's
obligated to look after me I'm a child
yeah yes
but you don't have responsibility to go
and ask for questions from I can ask my
father whatever I want and he should
answer me just like my sons can ask me
questions and I'll answer them no that's
a wisdom mentally no it's not a western
mentality that's the reason why that SIM
card don't work